[موسيقى]
أهلا ومرحبا بكم في مشاهدينا في
الولايات المتحدة وفي جميع أنحاء العالم
أنا مايكل هولمز في مركز CNN في
أتلانتا وبعض الأخبار العاجلة التي
تؤكد قيام الجيش الأمريكي بتنفيذ
غارة بالقرب من مطار بغداد أسفرت عن مقتل
قاسم سليماني القائد.  من
الأكراد يجبرون وحدة العمليات الخاصة الإيرانية النخبة
الآن الولايات المتحدة  كما أدى الضربة إلى
مقتل عضو بارز في قوات
الحشد الشعبي المدعومة من إيران
، وهي نفس المجموعة التي
حاول أنصارها اقتحام السفارة الأمريكية
في بغداد في وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع ، والآن
أصدر البنتاغون بيانًا
يقرأ جزئيًا بتوجيه من
الرئيس.  اتخذ الجيش الأمريكي
إجراءات دفاعية حاسمة لحماية الأفراد الأمريكيين في
الخارج بقتل قاسم
سليماني قائد
الحرس الثوري الإيراني يمكن أن يجبرنا.
تهدف الضربة إلى ردع خطط الهجوم الإيراني المستقبلية ،
وستواصل الولايات المتحدة
اتخاذ جميع الإجراءات اللازمة لحماية
شعبنا ومصالحنا أينما
كانوا حول العالم.